so there's now a movement an effort to
push the Biden dementia storyline the
Biden cognitive decline storyline and I
want to be really careful here because
everybody wants a hot take on this and
the truth is the hot takes are falling
flat guys two people on the left and on
the right with the hot takes on this
issue if you're looking for some kind of
black and white hot take on this turn
this off right now I'll give you a
second because you're not going to get
that for me if you're expecting me to
say for example Joe Biden is obviously
suffering from advanced dementia
couldn't be President and this alone is
a reason not to vote for him over Trump
if Biden is indeed the nominee you're
not gonna find that here on the other
hand if you're expecting me to say the
entire Joe Biden dementia story is a
coordinated effort involving Republicans
Trump and Russians you are not going to
find that here as well this is what's
going on I've been covering Joe Biden's
concerning cognitive incidents for a
long time now just like I've been
covering Donald Trump's Joe Biden is a
77 year old man who has clearly slowed
down over the last four years writing it
all off to his stutter is wrong go back
and look at his debate from 2012 with
Paul Ryan look at all sorts of other
stuff you will see that what is going on
right now is not Joe Biden's stutter I
find this concerning and I find it less
concerning than the cognitive decline
that we have apparently seen from Donald
Trump and if you give me the option of
two guys with possible cognitive decline
Biden and Trump I pick Biden over Trump
every single time even in the midst of
cognitive decline Biden would be better
than Trump Biden's VP would be better
than pence Biden would pick better
Supreme Court judges period okay so
there's no question about it
now there is no question that in
addition to the cognitive decline
questions being real and legitimate
there is also no doubt that both
Republicans and Bernie supporters have
scaled up their social media campaign
about Biden's cognitive decline
there are Bernie supporters sharing
Trump videos of Joe Biden's cognitive
decline there are Trump supporters
sharing videos made by Bernie supporters
purporting to show Joe Biden's cognitive
decline the Bernie supporters are
sharing the Biden videos because they
think it'll help Bernie beat Biden and
become the nominee I see that as
incredibly unlikely look at the polls
Michigan has Biden up 24 and 21 that's
the one state Bernie's counting on
tomorrow
maleeh mathematically wrong but I
understand why the Bernie supporters are
doing it the Trump supporters are
sharing the Biden dementia clips for two
reasons number one they want to just so
chaos within the Democratic primary they
see Biden as gaining they want to now so
doubt maybe help Bernie a little get the
thing to last as long as possible
and number two Trump supporters are
sharing that Biden dementia videos
because they want to be able to say you
guys have been saying Trump's cognitive
the cognitively declining so is Biden
look at these videos so I'm not going to
fall into any black-and-white nonsense
on this and we are actually unlikely to
do as well in terms of our viewership
over the next couple of weeks because
I'm not gonna do the black/white
nonsense that everybody's jumping in on
one way or the other you all know I've
been covering Biden for a very long time
we've been covering his political views
we've been covering his possible
cognitive decline I'm not going to start
sharing nonsense and Donald Trump
retweeted a doctored video of Biden
which now has been flagged as
manipulated by Twitter and other
platforms the video tweeted by Trump
social media director dance Covino and
retweeted by Trump purports to be
another one of these biden cognitive
incidents where it seems like biden is
saying we can only reelect donald trump
in reality the video is cut mid-sentence
and it's completely deceptive here's the
video as it's been presented turned his
primary from a campaign that's about
negative attacks into one about what
were for because we cannot get reelect
we cannot win this reelection
we could only reelect Donald Trump so
this makes it sound like Biden is saying
we can only reelect Donald Trump the
actual video has Biden saying if we
engage in a circular firing squad on the
Left we will certainly be reelecting
Donald Trump here's the full clip turn
from a campaign that's about negative
attacks into one about what were for
because we cannot get reelected we
cannot win this reelection
sadly this is one of the Biden attack
videos that was put out by Trump and his
team but it was widely shared by Bernie
supporters and it's just a bad look guys
it's a really bad look this is like if I
say in a video the Jews are the enemy of
the people white supremacists have said
for years and someone cuts it and says
what did you see what David Pakman said
and they show only me saying the Jews
are the enemy of the people
that's essentially what this is doesn't
matter what side you're on I get it I
get what's going on in the Democratic
primary and a lot of people are acting
out of desperation at this point and I
understand the desperation believe me we
should and can have the Biden cognitive
decline discussion but notice that half
the people having that discussion never
said a word about Trump's cognitive
decline aren't saying a word about
Bernie having a heart attack at age 77
like if you're going to talk about this
stuff talk about all of it or otherwise
you know that there's going to be
there's going to be real questions
raised about the motives of some of the
people participating in this and again I
share the concern I share the concern
I'm a progressive Biden as well to my
right I understand it but come on guys
let's let's get it together